welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we're
discussing growth mindset growth mindset
is one of the most interesting and
Powerful Concepts in all of psychology
growth mindset is essentially a way of
embracing Challenge and thinking about
your bodily and brain's response to
challenge in a way that allows you to
optimize your performance growth mindset
consists of many things which we will
discuss today and of course we will
discuss how to implement growth mindset
but some of the key features of growth
mindset are developing an ability to
distance your identity from The
Challenge you happen to be embracing now
that might come as a bit of a surprise
to many of you for instance we grow up
hearing we hope from time to time that
we are smart that we are talented that
we are a good athlete that we are a good
artist you know we like to think that we
are good at something or perhaps many
things but it turns out that the kind of
Praise or feedback that we receive that
attaches our identity to Performance can
actually undermine our performance and
believe it or not this is especially
problematic for people that perform well
in their Endeavors that's right if you
are somebody who performs well in school
or Athletics or music and you are told
that you are very smart that you're an
excellent student that you're an
excellent athlete or that you're an
excellent musician you have much to lose
if you at any moment do not perform well
and that's because your identity has
been integrated with your performance
somewhat counter-intuitively growth
mindset is the process of distancing
your identity from performance and
rather attaching your identity and your
efforts and your sense of motivation to
effort itself and to the process of
enjoying learning and getting better at
learning anything so today we are going
to discuss what growth mindset is and
what it isn't because it's often
discussed in terms that frankly are not
accurate to the science we will also
talk about another mindset which is the
stress is enhancing mindset that it
turns out can act synergistically with
growth mindset such that when you
combine growth mindset with the stresses
enhancing mindset you and anyone it's
been shown can vastly improve your
performance in essentially anything so
today's discussion will of course
explore the classic work of Carol dweck
who was really the founder of the growth
mindset field as well as some of the
newer research from people like David
Yeager Ali Crum and others who have
explored how growth mindset and stress
as enhancing mindsets can be applied
both in and out of the classroom in
children and adults and really in people
of all backgrounds by the end of today's
episode you will have a rich
understanding of the science as well as
many tools that you can apply in
everyday life in essentially any
Endeavor before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is eight sleep
eight sleep makes Smart mattress covers
with cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity there's absolutely no question
that sleep is the foundation of mental
health physical health and performance
when we're sleeping well and we're
sleeping long enough everything in our
daily life goes that much better now a
key component to getting a great night's
sleep is the temperature of your
sleeping environment and that's because
in order to fall and stay deeply asleep
your core body temperature actually has
to drop by about one to three degrees
con conversely in order to wake up
feeling refreshed your core body
temperature has to increase by about one
to three degrees with eight sleep
mattress covers you can cool or heat
your mattress at the beginning middle
and end of your night in order to
optimize your night's sleep I started
sleeping on an eight-sleep mattress
cover about two years ago and it has
dramatically improved the sleep that I
get each and every night if you'd like
to try eight sleep you can go to
eightsleep.com huberman and save up to
150 off their pod 3 cover eight sleep
currently ships in the USA Canada UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's eightsleep.com huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
Roca Rocco makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are the absolute highest
quality I've spent a lifetime working on
the biology of the visual system and I
can tell you that your visual system has
to contend with an enormous number of
different challenges in order for you to
be able to see clearly Roca understands
all of those challenges at the level of
the eye and the visual system within the
brain and they've designed their
eyeglasses and sunglasses so that no
matter what environment you're in you
can always see with Crystal Clarity
originally their glasses were designed
for sports and as a consequence all of
their glasses are extremely lightweight
and as well they won't slip off your
face even if you get sweaty however
despite being designed initially for
performance Roca eyeglasses and
sunglasses include a lot of different
styles that are designed for you to wear
to work or out to dinner as well as the
what I call the cyborg style they're
designed for cycling Etc if you'd like
to try Roca eyeglasses or sunglasses go
to Roka that's roka.com and enter the
code huberman to save 20 off your first
order again that's Roca roka.com and
enter the code huberman at checkout
let's talk about growth mindset growth
mindset as the name suggests is the idea
that we can get better at things that is
that our abilities are not fixed but
rather that our abilities are malleable
and at the core of growth mindset is the
idea that our brains can change and
indeed they can we refer to that ability
as neuroplasticity or the the nervous
system's ability to change in response
to experience now I've done several
episodes about neuroplasticity so that's
a topic unto itself but suffice to say
that neuroplasticity Brain Change can
occur throughout the entire lifespan it
is far more robust early in life from
birth until about age 25
neuroplasticity is sort of the default
process our brain is being shaped by our
everyday experiences but certainly from
age 25 and onward and certainly well
into people's 90s even it's been shown
the brain can change if we want it to it
can change for the worse of course
through injury or disease things of that
sort but it also can change for the
better through deliberate focused bouts
of learning we can learn new languages
we can learn art we can learn music we
can get smarter we can get better at
essentially anything if we devote our
attentional resources to learning those
things so really any discussion about
growth mindset has as a subtext a
discussion about neural elasticity
although today we aren't going to focus
so much on neuroplasticity meaning we
aren't going to focus so much on the
neural circuit and neurochemical changes
that underlie neuroplasticity because
I've covered those on previous episodes
we'll talk about them a little bit today
but we are mainly going to talk about
the data the studies from the field of
psychology applying growth mindset in
and out of the classroom in children and
adults and we are going to talk about
tools everyday tools that you can use to
enhance growth mindset for yourself and
perhaps for those around you if you care
to teach growth mindset which is you'll
learn later turns out to be an excellent
way to reinforce your own growth mindset
and we're going to talk about how to
apply those tools in a bunch of
different domains musical athletic
intellectual and on and on no discussion
of growth mindset would be complete
without mentioning that growth mindset
is the brainchild of my colleague Carol
dweck in the department of psychology at
Stanford University
today you'll learn how she discovered
growth mindset and you will learn how
others have taken that Discovery and
expanded upon it and especially its
application in and out of the classroom
to start off our discussion about growth
mindset however we need to Define what a
mindset is I think most of us think we
know what a mindset is we think oh it's
kind of a a mental stance where you know
we are positive or we are negative or we
believe something or we don't believe
something but a mindset actually has a
very specific definition and here I'm
referring to the definition provided by
Dr Ali Crum Ali Crum is also a professor
of psychology at Stanford she runs her
own laboratory working on stress-related
mindsets and other mindsets she's
actually been a guest on this podcast
previously highly recommend you listen
to that episode if you haven't already
Dr Crum defines a mindset as quote a
mental frame or lens that selectively
organizes and encodes information
and I think the key thing to highlight
there is organizes information because
as you all well know we are constantly
being bombarded with information from
the outside world sensory information
about what's going on with our visual
system what we're hearing what we're
seeing what we're feeling we are also
bombarded with internal sensations of
how full or empty our gut feels are we
hungry are we tired are we anxious are
we calm Etc so tons and tons of
information funneling into our brain and
mindsets really help us organize that
information such that we pay attention
to certain things and not others and we
respond to certain things and not others
okay so here I'm not trying to put
additional language on something simple
in order to make it complex I'm trying
to put a little bit of language that is
that a mindset does many things but it
mainly organizes information I'll add to
that for specific actions or inactions
in a way that allows us to simplify our
world in a way that allows us to make
certain choices and do away with
thinking about and acting on other types
of information the other thing about
mindsets is that they include entire
narratives and most of the time we
aren't even aware of how those
narratives are operating
meaning we don't walk around looking at
opportunities in the world like the
opportunity to get better at Fitness or
a sport or music or arithmetic or
languages or anything for that matter
thinking okay what is my mental frame or
lens that selectively organizes and
encodes information we don't do that
instead what we have are stories and
those stories are usually attached to
our sense of identity like I'll just use
myself for instance I do not think of
myself as a good musician in fact I
can't read music I'm terrible at playing
instruments I like listening to music
but I consider myself a terrible
musician right I've really assigned a
value or I've assigned my value to music
and my relationship to music right we
tend to do that we can also do it in the
opposite direction right I'm running a
laboratory for a long time been in
science for you know close to three
decades so if you ask me you know do I
feel proficient at science I'd say yeah
I'm proficient at science I know how to
do experiment setup experiments write
research papers write grants Etc I'm
pretty good at it right we tend to
decide if we are good or bad at things
and we tend to integrate those with our
identity somewhat or a lot to depending
on whether or not you know we're a
professional or amateur how much we
engage in an activity the point being
that mindsets include all of these
narratives and often those narratives
are visible to us if we think about them
but most of the time we are moving
through the world meaning school work
relationships and all our endeavors
without a lot of careful thought about
the narratives we carry and the beauty
of growth mindset is that it forces us
to step back and ask ourselves some
simple questions these are questions
that you could ask yourself right now
and in fact I highly recommend you do
you could ask yourself for instance what
have I been told I'm really good at you
should also ask yourself what have I
been told I'm really poor at that I'm
just not good at what have I told myself
I'm really good at and what have I told
myself I'm really bad at and then a
second set of questions is what am I
good at and why did it come naturally to
me did I apply myself for many years
meaning did I apply a lot of effort to
learning that thing or perhaps both
right and then it's also important to
ask yourself why am I not good at other
things is it simply because you've never
applied yourself with those things or is
it because you tried and had an early
failure or perhaps you tried and tried
and tried for many years and you
continue to fail at that thing or you
just didn't reach a level of proficiency
that made you want to pursue it further
in asking yourselves those questions you
are asking yourself not just what you're
good at and bad at and why you should
also be thinking about where the
messages of being good at something or
being bad at something arrived from did
they arrive from outside you meaning
from your parents from your coaches from
your teachers or was it the case that
despite a lot of positive feedback you
just sort of decided you weren't good at
something or conversely was it the case
that despite a lot of negative feedback
that you would never be good at
something or that you weren't good at
something that you continue to persist
because there are certainly people like
that the more negative feedback they get
the more they dig their heels in to
prove themselves as capable of becoming
good at something so I do recommend as
we March forward in this conversation
you think about those questions what am
I good at what am I bad at why am I good
at those things why am I bad at those
things and ask yourself to what extent
your labels that is your identity is
attached to the things that you are good
at or bad at and the reason I'd like you
to ask yourself those questions is that
next we're going to talk about some
research from Dr Carol dweck's
laboratory that was really the seed of
the entire field of growth mindset it
relates to a specific set of experiments
that really show that the specific
feedback we get meaning whether or not
we get feedback that is attached to our
identity like a label like smart or
great athlete or talented sends us down
a very different path of performance in
the short and long run
as compared to whether or not we receive
feedback that's based on effort meaning
you tried really hard or you really seem
to apply yourself under conditions where
you're getting the right answer over
time because you simply refuse to quit
those are two very Divergent sets of
feedback and as you'll learn in a moment
the sorts of feedback that we get
especially early in life or early in an
Endeavor so this doesn't just apply to
young kids this applies to adults too
who are taking on a new skill or trying
to expand on an existing skill those two
Divergent forms of feedback get
integrated into our core beliefs about
what we think is possible for us in a
given Endeavor and the great news is we
can also modify those core beliefs
simply by changing the feedback that we
give ourselves the research paper I'd
like to discuss briefly that beautifully
embodies the runway that led to the
discovery of growth mindset is paper
from Dr Carol dweck as well as her
colleague Claudia Mueller and the title
of the paper essentially says it all the
title is praise for intelligence can
undermine children's motivation and
performance
right that should be surprising that
praise for intelligence can undermine
motivation and performance I would have
thought and I think many people probably
believe that if you tell a child or an
adult that they're really good at
something and you're genuine about that
feedback meaning they're performing well
and you say great you're doing really
well you're so smart you're so talented
that their performance would continue to
improve that it would bolster their
motivation to engage in that activity
which hopefully they enjoy but
regardless provided that it's a safe
activity it's educational or what have
you that it would serve to encourage
them right the kid thinks not only am I
engaging in this activity but I'm
getting positive feedback presumably
from people that I care about or whose
opinion I care about wouldn't that serve
to elevate performance
it does not in fact the exact opposite
happens so I'll just give you a few of
the key takeaways from this study
the way it was done is very interesting
they essentially gave feedback about
performance that was linked up with a
child's intelligence telling kid they're
smart they're talented that they can
learn things really easily or that
they're very good at learning this sort
of thing and they call that intelligence
feedback
or they gave them what was called effort
feedback the simple way to think about
effort feedback is that it's more
attached to verbs as opposed to labels
so effort feedback consists of things
like
you tried really hard on that problem it
was great the way that you applied
effort it was great the way that you
persisted it was great the way that even
when you got the wrong answer you spent
10 minutes thinking about it and then
you tried again and again or in some
cases even if they didn't get the right
answer telling them well even though you
didn't get the right answer it's really
terrific that you continue to try Okay
so intelligence feedback was the sort of
feedback that was tied to labels of
identity things like smart talented Etc
whereas effort feedback was tied to
verbs choices behavioral and cognitive
choices that children made in an effort
to learn or get better at something so
in this study which included over 100
children they either got the
intelligence type feedback or the effort
type feedback or there was a control
group that didn't get either the
intelligence or the effort type feedback
and then they looked at a number of
different outcomes so I'll just
highlight a few examples of what they
found first of all the kids that got the
intelligence-based feedback when they
were then later offered problem sets
that were either challenging or were of
the sort that they knew they could
perform well on they tended to select
problems that they knew they could
perform well on these are what were
referred to as performance goals in
other words they picked problems that
allowed them to continue to get the
praise that they had received previously
about being smart or talented whereas
the kids that got feedback about their
strong effort when later presented with
problems that were either easy or hard
more often than not they picked the
harder problems that stood to teach them
more so that's striking it says that if
you tell a kid that they're smart or
talented and that's the reason why they
perform well
when they encounter challenges they are
likely to go with the least amount of
challenge so that they can continue to
receive that praise or feedback whereas
if you receive praise and feedback for
your strong effort then later you tend
to pick environments problem sets Etc
that allow you to exert the very effort
that got you the praise in the first
place so in both cases these children
are essentially attached to the praise
right in some sense I mean we like to
think that they enjoy these activities
and they're benefiting from them as well
but in both cases the praise really
serves to reinforce a certain pattern of
behavior but in the case of giving
intelligence feedback the kids are
really just trying to reinforce being
told that they're smarter talented as
opposed to reinforcing the engagement in
the activity that got them the praise in
the first place
and the converse is also true when kids
are told hey you really tried hard and
that's great or I like how you persisted
or you're so persistent I can really see
how persistent you are in trying to get
the right answer even if you don't get
the right answer well then when you
present those kids with additional
challenges they work very hard to stay
in Challenge and guess what no surprise
the kids that are rewarded for effort
and that continue to pick harder
problems outperform the kids that are
given the intelligence praise and
feedback by a large margin so what does
this tell us this tells us that the
narratives that we hear from others of
course reinforce certain patterns of
behavior what else does this tell us
this tells us that if you're a parent or
teacher you have to be very careful
about giving feedback to a child that is
attached to their identity around an
endeavor
especially if they're performing well at
that endeavor right now of course if a
child is not performing well at
something you also don't want to tell
them that they're stupid right you don't
want to tell them that they're deficient
right but that's a rare occurrence in
the classroom one would hope that's a
rare occurrence on the field one would
hope but what's very common very very
common is that when we see children or
adults performing well we tend to give
them identity labels as a way to try and
reinforce whatever Behavior we observe
and we like now the other thing they
looked at in the study besides whether
or not these kids would pick hard or
easier challenges down the line where
the actual raw performance on cognitive
problems and these data I must say are
just so interesting
they took the kids and they gave them
all the same problem sets and all the
kids across the board whether or not
they were getting intelligence praise or
effort praise or they were in the
control group we're performing more or
less the same way they were getting some
of these questions right some of these
questions wrong
then they gave them praise after
they completed those problems they
either got intelligence praise you're so
smart you're so talented or they got
effort praise you tried so hard you
really persisted that's fantastic then
later they gave them another set of
problems and they looked at performance
now remember the first time around all
the kids got some of the questions right
and some of the questions wrong so
there's room for improvement for
everybody
what they found was absolutely striking
the kids that were in the control group
so they didn't get any specific form of
Praise they perform more or less the
same way as they did before so if they
were getting 75 percent of the answers
right the first time they got 75 percent
of the answers right the second time 25
wrong in both cases
the kids that were in the intelligence
praise group that you're so smart you're
so talented praise group their
performance went down significantly
whereas the kids that were in the effort
praise group their performance increased
significantly okay so this is a
bi-directional effect where giving
intelligence praise reduces performance
and giving effort praise improves
performance which is absolutely striking
and tells you everything you need to
know which is if you're a parent you're
a teacher and of course as we all give
ourselves feedback
rewarding yourself for effort is the
best way to improve performance
rewarding yourself based on identity
labels so smart so talented you're a
great athlete Etc all that stare in the
mirror and do self-affirmation stuff can
actually undermine performance and in
fact it does undermine performance it
may not do it right away but eventually
it does and in a moment I'll explain why
the other thing this study looked at
that I just have to mention is this
notion of persistence so remember
earlier I said that the kids that got
intelligence praise tended to pick
easier problems down the line whereas
the kids that got effort praise tended
to pick harder problems it turns out
that the kids that got intelligence
praise also tended to take on fewer
problems overall they tended to limit
the total number of challenges that they
engaged in whereas the kids that got the
effort praise that you worked so hard
you're so determined that was so
impressive how you just kept going even
when you got some answers wrong those
kids not only opted for harder
challenges they not only performed
better but they also took on many more
challenges so these data really made
clear that the effort praise is the way
to go now I know many people have heard
this whole thing about don't reward the
person reward the effort reward the
verbs as I'm referring to it but it's
actually pretty rare that we hear effort
rewarded in everyday settings and it is
very common for us to overhear
intelligence praise or Talent praise you
know a kid comes home with a trophy and
we tell them you're a great athlete
right a kid comes home with a great
report card you know you're so smart
congratulations a kid comes home with
some sort of win in their world and we
tend to give them a label because we
like to think that that label will get
internalized and they'll start to view
themselves as a winner we tell them you
can do anything you're a winner you're a
winner and of course you don't want to
tell children or yourself or any other
adult you're a loser right we do not
want to do that you don't want to
undermine performance that way but it's
very clear based on This research and a
lot of other papers similar to it that
we all have a giant blind spot sitting
in our psychological field when we are
getting and receiving praise that really
it is the sort of praise that's attached
to the very efforts that led to the
results that will lead to even improved
results over time okay so this paper is
really truly important it's a landmark
paper in the field of psychology
motivation learning and performance and
that's why I'm discussing it in such
detail here but it actually includes one
additional piece of information that I
also think everyone should know about
and that is the tendency for children
who get intelligence praise
to misrepresent their performance on
subsequent efforts
what do I mean by that basically what
I'm saying is in this paper they had the
children perform on a given task and
then they either got intelligence praise
you're so smart you're so talented or
effort praise you worked so hard you're
so diligent you kept going even when you
were faced with results you didn't like
and then they had them do a series of
other tasks and then report their
results to other kids and what they
found is that children who get
intelligence praise when they need to
report their scores either by walking up
to the board and putting a little Mark
where their particular score is or
telling another student what their score
was or even writing it down on a piece
of paper covertly so that's not visibly
being compared to all the other scores
the kids that got intelligence praise
tend to lie about their score
and as you could imagine they tend to
lie in the direction of making
themselves appear as having performed
better than they actually did so this is
a pretty Sinister aspect of intelligence
praise that we don't often hear about
even if you've heard telling a person
that they are smart or talented can
ultimately undermine performance rarely
if ever do we hear that telling someone
that they're smart or talented
can increase the probability that that
person is going to misrepresent their
performance in the future and that's
true regardless of whether or not they
perform pretty well or not in the past I
mean you could imagine that the kids
that were told that they were
intelligent that they're talented that
those kids you know if they were doing
well and then suddenly did poorly that
they Slide the score up a little bit we
don't want anyone to do that but you can
imagine how a young kid might do that to
kind of preserve their ego but no in
some cases these kids are already
performing pretty well they're not
getting 100 but they're performing in
the top bracket and yet if they received
intelligence praise they're still more
likely to lie about their performance
increasing it further still whereas the
kids that receive the effort praise do
no such thing they Faithfully represent
their performance and as I mentioned
before for many reasons that we'll talk
about in a few minutes meaning the
mechanisms and what's really going on in
the heads of these kids that get effort
praise they're performing better than
everybody else so just to illustrate how
important the findings in the study
really are the paper was Paul published
in 1998 but just two years prior in 1996
there was a survey of parents asking to
what extent do you believe that
intelligence is fixed and 85 percent
answered that they thought that
intelligence was fixed that means they
believe that the brain was sort of a
vessel of fixed size that of course when
we're born into the world it's kind of
empty we don't have any knowledge but
that the job of schooling was to teach
kids things and reveal an intelligence
capacity that was innate and that
couldn't be increased upon whereas
nowadays we really understand mainly
through our deeper understanding of
neuroplasticity and how the brain learns
that indeed the brain can learn and that
intelligence is not fixed however in
1998 when these studies were done most
people were of the core belief that
intelligence is fixed that it cannot be
improved upon and these results really
drive home the fact that the type of
feedback we get about our performance
even when our performance is good can
undermine our future performance or if
we receive feedback of the effort praise
type the you tried so hard you're so
persistent type that our abilities can
indeed improve and when you look at any
intelligence test if you look at
standard IQ test or you you know go way
out onto the other end of the Continuum
in terms of intelligence testing you
look at emotional intelligence it is
very clear that anyone and everyone can
improve their scores on those exams and
in fact can improve the various aspects
of intelligence because in fact there
are many different forms of intelligence
through dedicated effort so this paper
was really ahead of its time and it's
really what seeded the entire field of
growth mindset and the understanding of
what that is so now I'd like to shift
our attention to not just how getting
one form of Praise or another form of
Praise can diminish or enhance
performance but really to ask why that
would be how that is because in that
understanding there's a very simple set
of tools of narratives that you can tell
yourself or that you can tell a child as
they are attempting to learn that can
greatly enhance your or their ability to
learn before we go any further however I
know many of you are listening to this
with an eye toward the tools meaning you
want to know what the tools are that you
can Implement well earlier I had you ask
some questions what are you good at what
have you been told you're good at and
how did you arrive at being good at
those things I also encourage you to
think about what you've been told you're
bad at
or less good at and what you tell
yourself you're bad at and less good at
and how you arrived at that conclusion
right now I'd like you to ask yourself
what is your typical narrative when you
are engaging in things that you believe
you are good at and what is your typical
narrative meaning your internal dialogue
in your head when you're engaging in
things that you are not good at or if
you're not engaging in those things when
you think about engaging in those things
and the tool that's very effective to
apply even just in your own mind is to
start shifting your narrative from those
performance narratives of being really
good at something or bad at something
which are In fairness are the labels I'm
using here but that's for sake of
discussion and Clarity and to start to
shift those narratives towards effort
related narratives so I'll use myself as
an example I'm pretty good at learning
and remembering things cognitive
information
I'm pretty terrible at playing music in
fact I'm downright terrible if I were to
step back from those two statements
I could take an intelligence type praise
narrative and tell myself okay I'm
um I have a great memory right that's
that's a intelligence praise type
narrative or I could tell myself the
truth which is I tend to spend a lot of
time with information in different forms
I listen to it I read it I write it down
I highlight it I put it up on a
whiteboard I tell myself that
information again in my head I think
about it in different contexts I tell
other people about it that's how I
developed a good memory for certain
types of information and that's still
how I continue to build my memory and my
information Bank in my head to this day
it's not because I have a quote unquote
great memory it's because I engage in
certain verb processes to build up that
memory okay I can also take a look at
the let's call it the negative statement
I am abysmal at music which frankly is a
fair statement and I could say okay I'm
just a terrible musician I have no
musical sense I have no musical ability
those are labels of the intelligence
type labels
or I could look at the verbs
this is also true
I have never really spent a lot of time
trying to learn an instrument I failed
early on at least in my mind I failed to
get the results I wanted and so I
stopped playing
I made the dog next door Howell which by
the way I did so I stopped playing
I ceased the effort process and so in
looking at it through that lens yes I'm
a terrible musician but I'm a terrible
musician as a consequence of having
never really engaged in the types of
behaviors and effort over time that
would have allowed me to be anything but
a terrible musician now I'm not asking
you to do this exercise simply as a way
to Puff yourself up about the things
you're good at and reward yourself for
all the effort that went into it nor am
I asking you to look at the things that
you're not good at and trying to take
away some of the shame and blame
although that would be a good thing as
well
that led to the fact that you're not
good at these things the reason I'm
requesting that you ask those questions
of yourself is that they can start to
give you a sense of the actual tools and
how those tools are implemented in order
to get better at the things that you
want to get better at and and this is a
very important and to not set yourself
up for getting worse at the things that
you already think you're good at because
as we'll soon talk about when we attach
performance labels to things that we are
really good at we internalize that sense
of self oh I'm good at this particular
thing in my case if I gave a performance
label or an intelligence label it would
be of the sort okay I have a great
memory but what happens when someone
gives themselves or hears a performance
or intelligence label around something
that they're good at and then has an
error or has a period where they're not
that good at something well if you
internalized a sense of identity around
performing well at that thing and then
at some point you don't perform well you
will also attach your identity to that
diminished performance whereas if you
attach effort verbs to why you got good
at something as well as why you are not
good at something well then there's only
room for improvement why do I say that
well when we're talking about effort
we're talking about verbs that is
inherent to you if you did it in one
context you can do it in another whereas
ability and performance it's not the
case that if you have a good memory You
Are by default a good musician that
might be the case but in my case
certainly it's not the point being that
when you think about the effort
processes that you've engaged before and
over and over again that allows you to
continue to get better in a given domain
even when or perhaps we should say
especially when you stop getting the
results you want or you start getting
poor results and that effort process of
practicing a lot many repetitions
analyzing why you didn't get something
right that can be engaged in a lot of
different Endeavors across domains as we
say so when we talk about verbs like
effort or persistence or practicing a
lot or analyzing errors and why you did
something incorrectly and then getting
back to the drawing board as it's called
when you start to think about your
successes and your failures through
those lenses through the lens of verbs
then you're really talking about
something that's Central to who you are
it's how you're wired it's Machinery
that exists in your brain and nervous
system and body that you can engage that
time and anytime as many of you know
I've been taking ag1 daily since 2012.
so I'm delighted that they're sponsoring
the podcast eg1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that's designed to meet
all of your foundational nutrition needs
now of course I try to get enough
servings of vitamins and minerals
through whole food sources that include
vegetables and fruits every day but
oftentimes I simply can't get enough
servings but with ag1 I'm sure to get
enough vitamins and minerals and the
probiotics that I need and it also
contains adaptogens to help buffer
stress simply put I always feel better
when I take ag1 I have more focus and
energy and I sleep better and it also
happens to taste great for all these
reasons whenever I'm asked if you could
take Just One supplement what would it
be I answer ag1 if you'd like to try ag1
go to drinkag1.com huberman to claim a
special offer from now until August 12
2023 ag-1 is giving away 10 free travel
packs plus a year supply of vitamin D3
K2 again if you go to drinkag1.com
huberman you can claim the special offer
of 10 free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 okay so I've
been talking about cognitive or
psychological processes and the basic
take home is that labels of intelligence
labels of identity undermine performance
and a striking aspect of that by the way
which I failed to mention earlier but I
should have is that if we receive those
labels of being a high performer smart
talented Etc either before or after
a given task or game or exam
it still has a detrimental effect in
both cases meaning you tell someone
heading into something you're a great
athlete you are so smart you're going to
do so well on this exam you undermine
their performance or if they take the
exam and afterwards before you see their
scores or even after they score let's
say they get an A plus they get
everything perfect and you say you are
so smart you are so talented you are
undermining the performance on the next
exam that's how striking these results
are and again they've been shown again
and again in different populations of
students and adults conversely it's
striking how powerful the effort labels
can be at improving performance
conversely and fortunately the same is
true for effort-based praise so if
before a kid or adult heads into a
competition or exam or preparation for a
competition and exam you say you know
what I know you to be a really dedicated
worker you really persist you know how
to do hard things you really dig your
heels when it gets hard and you overcome
challenges if you do that before that
child or adult heads into challenge they
will perform better and if after an exam
or performance or practice whatever the
effort happens to be you tell them you
really worked hard I love the way that
even when you know you got kicked in the
shin and you're limping along there and
you're hurt you continue to play or even
when you know everyone else went to
sleep and you continue to study although
by the way I do encourage people to get
enough sleep there are times in which
let's face it the person who stays up
latest studying provides they get enough
sleep
they're getting the extra hours in right
I might have been that kid in college or
tried to be that kid in college
if you reward effort after the effort
you also set the mind the brain of that
child or adult up to provide more effort
to future endeavors so it's very clear
it doesn't matter if the timing of the
praise comes before or after a given
bout of effort or performance you give
identity praise before performance
diminishes you give identity praise
after
subsequent performance diminishes you
give effort praise before performance
goes up you give effort praise after
performance goes up so I know I sound a
little bit like a broken record but we
hear so often about growth mindset about
giving the right form of Praise but it's
not often that we are told when to give
that praise and the short answer of
course is doesn't matter in fact we
should always be striving to give others
and ourselves praise that is correctly
attached to genuine effort and that word
correctly is important here I'm not
saying you know take a kid who performed
poorly on an exam because they kind of
loafed or the kid that was just
shuffling their feet out on the soccer
field and say hey great you know you you
worked so hard when they didn't you know
we know when we're being lied to or when
we're lying to ourselves
but that should give you a sense of
control not a sense of lack of control
because ultimately effort is something
that we can control in fact whenever I
hear the term control what you can
control I get a little bit nauseated and
a little bit irritated too because it's
never clear what people are referring to
when they say control what you can
control focus on what you can control
what's the thing that we all really can
control it's our level of persistence
and our level of effort and of course we
all have different circumstances such
that persistence and effort can be
harder in certain circumstances and for
certain people certainly but at the end
of the day at the end of the year and at
the end of our life really the only
thing that you really truly can control
is where you place your attention and
where you place your effort those are
the two things that are really inherent
to you and your nervous system no one
can do the effort for us no one can
direct our attention for us
things and people can try and divert or
distract our attention and our effort
but ultimately effort and attention that
is intrinsic motivation come as the name
suggests directly from us okay so it's
clear that we have a striking set of
results in the literature and again
major hat tip to Carol dweck and her
colleagues for making this discovery
right it is what eventually led to the
discovery of growth mindset and it's
what we're really building up to here
okay so this early work from dweck and
colleagues and by early I mean late 90s
right
is really spectacular it really
transformed the way that we think about
education and learning in general and in
fact neuroplasticity but what it didn't
answer is why you know why is it that
effort praise leads to better
performance and intelligence praise
identity praise leads to diminished
performance and it turns out that the
answer resides in how people respond to
errors how they respond to feedback that
they did not want and there's a really
nice study that looked at this
mechanistically in the brain to ask
what's going on under the hood meaning
within the brain when people who have
one mindset or another
adopt a growth mindset that is the idea
that if they engage in effort that they
can get better at things or if they have
what's called a fixed mindset this idea
that if they're not performing well it
must be because they just simply can't
perform well they don't have the
capacity or the ability to perform well
so the study I'm referring to is a study
first author mangles last author no
surprise Carol dweck and it's entitled
why do beliefs about intelligence
influence learning success a social
cognitive Neuroscience model
I'm not going to go into all the details
of the study but the study used what's
called erps event related potentials
event related potentials
are measured by putting a cap on the
skull that has a bunch of electrodes but
they don't penetrate the skull they're
picking up electrical potentials that
correlate with shifts in brain activity
now an advantage of erps is that it's
pretty non-invasive you can even do it
on babies you don't have to cut into the
skull you don't have to remove any skin
as you would if you were going to you
know put electrodes down into the brain
which essentially is neurosurgery and
it's not as disruptive as being put into
a functional magnetic Imaging machine
where you're put into a tube and you
have to lie motionless for an hour or
more actually it was in an MRI machine
not for any clinical reason but just as
a diagnostic scan recently and nowadays
they allow you to watch Netflix in there
or do something but you have to stay
very very still so it's hard for a lot
of people to do that but it can be done
if you need it to be done you do it but
erps are great because people can come
into the laboratory put on this skull
cap it's got this funny thing or it
looks funny with all these little wires
coming out of it and you can get a
fairly good measure of
Global levels of activity across the
brain you can't really pinpoint fine
structures and you can't look at brain
activity deep in the brain that's
probably the major drawback of looking
at these erps but you can see global
shifts in activity across the brain and
the other Advantage is you can do that
while people are engaging a lot of
different types of tasks you can move
around a lot whereas when you're in an
MRI machine you're in that little tube
you can't really do much so this study
had people equipped with these skull
caps looks like a kind of like a hoodie
with a bunch of wires coming out of it
and they had them
play a game basically what they did is
they were asked questions these are
trivia type questions like what's the
capital of Australia Australians you're
not allowed to answer that question but
everyone else should try and then here
I'm paraphrasing people indicate their
confidence in how accurate they were
with the response okay so they ask them
a question like what's the capital of
Australia the person would answer and
then they say how confident are you on a
scale of say one to ten
that you got the answer correct and then
they were given two pieces of feedback
and the first piece of feedback provided
information only about their response
accuracy were they right or were they
not right
and then the second feedback was they
got the correct answer so this is a
pretty clever experimental design
because it allowed the researchers to
look at people's thinking as they're
trying to get the right answer then
compare that to how confident they were
that they had the right answer right you
could imagine that if someone was really
confident like if you ask me what's your
name and I say Andrew what's my
confidence that my name is Andrew 75
just kidding 100 okay 100 whereas if you
asked me
um I was confronted this the other day
uh in your physics class when they
talked about the right hand rule which
is if you're listening don't don't worry
about it it's just when you put out your
index finger your middle finger and your
thumb with your right hand in the right
hand rule is the magnetic field the the
middle finger the index finger the thumb
and I'm pretty sure that it's pretty
sure that it's the the magnetic field is
the the middle finger that's the vector
of the middle finger but how confident
am I in this result I don't know maybe
50 because it's been a while since I've
looked at this stuff and I should know
this but I haven't looked at so 50 when
you give people these kinds of questions
while recording brain activity you're
getting a lot of information you're
looking at accuracy you're also looking
at confidence you're looking at lack of
confidence and you can correlate that
with different patterns of brain
activity now they had essentially two
groups of people in the study one group
had an intelligence mindset they
believed intelligence was more or less
fixed the other had what we call a
growth mindset they believed that
through effort that intelligence was
malleable that people could learn new
information including themselves they
could learn new information
and you wouldn't necessarily think that
these two groups would show different
patterns of brain activity in response
to getting things right or wrong while
their brain was being imaged but in fact
that's exactly what happened there's a
certain waveform of activity the name
isn't really important you call it the
P3 wave in these Erp experiments P3 wave
is a certain pattern of activity that
emerged during the presentation to the
subject that they gotten something wrong
so the P3 wave it's just a little
blippin neural activity in the brain
correlated with when people were told
nope you got that one wrong okay and
what was really interesting is that the
height of the P3 this let's just call it
an error signal because it correlated
with the error signal this nope you got
it wrong signal in the brain that signal
was larger in people with a fixed
mindset as opposed to in people with the
growth mindset
now what was especially interesting is
that the location of that activity was
above a brain area called the interior
cingulate cortex the ACC the anterior
cingulate cortex is a structure involved
in many different functions in the brain
but one of its primary functions is that
in the front of the ACC what we call the
rostral or anterior ACC
ivity there tends to correlate with
emotional responses it tends to
correlate with our internal sense
so-called enteroception whereas in the
dorsal ACC meaning the top of the ACC
activity there tends to correlate with
cognitive information and cognitive
appraisal meaning this structure has a
lot of different functions but it's got
a little area within it that tends to be
more related to our emotional or somatic
responses to things and it's got another
area inside of it the tends to be more
related to our thinking our cognition
and what was really interesting is that
in the group that had the fixed mindset
when they were told that they got
something wrong there tended to be a
greater signal in that rostral or
anterior ACC meaning they had a bigger
emotional response to it or at least the
neural activity suggested that whereas
people with a growth mindset when
presented with ah you got something
wrong the error signal the error signal
within their brain tended to reside or
even to shift toward areas that are
associated with cognitive appraisal and
so the conclusion of this study as well
as other studies using functional
magnetic resonance imaging that have
looked at similar tasks is that when
people have a growth mindset and they
are presented with the information that
they got something wrong rather than
just feel it as a somatic response or an
emotional response they tend to appraise
it they tend to direct their attentional
resources toward trying to understand
what the error was and why they got that
error and this I believe is absolutely
fundamental to understanding the
distinction between a fixed mindset and
a growth mindset because perhaps you've
seen these lists these you know
side-by-side lists that you know a fixed
mindset versus a growth mindset you know
a fixed mindset is one in which you're
trying to look smart that you're not so
focused on effort that your response to
setbacks is to give up you know and your
academic and other forms of performance
tends to be low whereas in a growth
mindset your goal tends to be to learn
you tend to Value effort more you tend
to respond to setbacks by working harder
and your performance is higher and I'm
not trying to make light of these lists
these lists are important because they
help us organize our information and
differentiate between a fixed versus
growth mindset but they don't tell us
why focusing on effort and engaging more
effort would actually translate into
higher performance for instance you
could imagine a scenario where the exact
opposite is true right we can make up a
just so story where if your identity is
so rigidly fixed to high performance
you're likely to outwork everybody right
that seems like a logical conclusion as
well but that's not the way it plays out
it's when your identity is attached to
yourself sense of ability to engage in
ongoing effort especially when you
receive signals that you're getting
things wrong or not performing well that
is tied to elevated performance in the
study using erps tells us that's likely
to be the case because of how people who
have a growth mindset Focus their
attention when they're told nope you got
that wrong or when people think they got
something right right they give an
answer and they say what's your
confidence level and they say 90 maybe
99 maybe even 100 percent it's wrong
people who have a fixed mindset
focus on the emotional response to that
more of their brain resources are
devoted to I got it wrong I thought I
got it right then the people who have a
growth mindset who are thinking wait
okay then what was that answer and how
could I possibly get that answer wrong
I'm going to figure that out okay now as
you're hearing this you're probably
thinking oh no I'm somebody who
reflexively gets disappointed when I get
something wrong well fortunately this is
not just about that 100 milliseconds to
five seconds after you're told something
is wrong you can shift from a fixed
mindset to a growth mindset response in
fact that's an important tool that we
all need to learn how to implement we
all suffer from fixed mindset all suffer
from fixed mindset in certain Endeavors
and when we get things wrong especially
when there's some embarrassment or shame
which often accompanies when we think we
were very right we're convinced we're
right that fixed mindset can really
hijack our emotional response
but
there are a lot of data that point to
the fact that at those moments if we
think okay I'm going to step back from
that and I'm going to just think about
the error I'm going to think about what
led to the error and I'm going to start
devoting my intentional resources to
that process
that process itself can be built up over
time such that we start to outweigh the
fixed mindset with growth mindset simply
by devoting our attentional resources to
the error acknowledging it happened
maybe feeling something about it maybe
not it's really hard to control our
feelings what we can control as I
mentioned before is our effort and our
attention so focusing our attention on
why we got something wrong and really
digging into that that's growth mindset
in action so you'll notice as we have
this discussion about the more
mechanistic underpinnings of growth
mindset is that we're not talking about
psychological terms as much we're not
talking about ego protection we're not
talking about identity now all of those
things are extremely important but the
problem with things like ego protection
and identity is that when we are faced
with results that we don't want and we
are faced with those results in a real
world context like we're not getting the
results we want in school in work in
athletics in relationships Etc
we hear these messages and we try to for
instance you know set our ego aside or
you know not attach our identity so much
to what is happening but it's really
really hard and it's really really hard
because
statements like set your ego aside or
don't attach yourself to it so much are
wonderful aspirations but there's no
actual process that one can go through
by oneself that allows you to
immediately disentangle yourself from
your ego right I mean there's this whole
process of ego dissolution that we
talked about in the episode with Robin
cardard Harris but none of that was
directed at specific challenges that one
is undertaking in real time right so
when you're faced with results that you
don't like you can't simply step back
nor should you expect yourself to be
able to step back and say oh I'm not
going to get upset about this error
right it makes perfect sense why you
would get upset about not getting the
results that you want however once you
start to understand some of the
mechanistic underpinnings of what will
allow you to rescue your performance
that is to start focusing on those
errors from a more cognitive and a
slightly less emotional stance or even a
combination of emotional and cognitive
right because it's very hard to suppress
our emotional response to something but
oftentimes we can enhance our
attentional or cognitive response to
Something in parallel with that and in
doing so we can kind of Rob some of the
emotional response
and when we do that sort of thing it's
hard and anytime we do hard things we
generally want to know that the doing of
those hard things is working that it's
in service to something and the study I
just reviewed as well as what I'm going
to talk about next really points to the
fact that building up a practice a
capacity of focusing on one's effort on
focusing on the errors one made from a
cognitive standpoint and really trying
to understand what led to those errors
is the basis it's the Cornerstone of
building up growth mindset it does
however require that we don't just tell
ourselves to focus on effort and the
errors and analyzing those errors it
also requires an additional piece which
is what we're going to talk about now
I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge our sponsor inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
meet your health goals I'm a big
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test
however with a lot of blood tests out
there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health inside tracker's ultimate plan
now includes measures of both apob and
of insulin which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off okay
so by now I like to think that we all
understand what growth mindset is and
what differentiates it from a fixed
mindset however just understanding what
growth mindset is and how having a
desire to implement it and a bit of
understanding of how to implement it
turns out to be necessary but not
sufficient there's an additional piece
that we need to accomplish the good news
is that additional piece is very
straightforward to understand if we zoom
out and we start to really understand
that growth mindset is really a way of
connecting motivation to cognition it's
taking this thing that we call
motivation which is of course what we
all want we all want to be motivated we
all want to be effort driven Etc
and we take motivation and we tie it to
a set of specific thoughts or thought
processes that we can control
that is Far and Away different than
looking at motivation simply as an
emotional or an internal state of quote
unquote feeling motivated and in fact
that's what most people including myself
default to we want to feel motivated so
fortunately we try and get good sleep
which is essential that really helps for
daytime mood focus and alertness and
thereby motivation we hydrate we
exercise we might even drink caffeine as
a way to increase our level of alertness
and motivation and all of that is
finding good in fact all of that is
encouraged although I would say that the
caffeine part is optional but all those
other things are encouraged toward
mental health physical health and
performance and motivation but what
growth mindset is really about is it's
taking this thing that we call
motivation and it's saying okay what are
the specific types of thoughts and
actually the specific thoughts the
specific cognitive processes that will
allow us to feel more motivated
especially under conditions where we
feel something is hard where we are not
getting the results we want and in order
to master that process we need to
embrace another mindset that's right in
order to access growth mindset it's very
clear that we need to be able to think
about errors and we need to overcome
errors and we need to devote our
attention to errors and we need to
devote our attention to reframing what's
going on in our head when we're feeling
not motivated Etc and all of that is
really hard to do from a purely
psychological standpoint but there's
this additional mindset which has to do
with our mindset around stress and
frustration itself that can allow us to
access growth mindset far more easily
and this mindset around stress actually
has a name it's called the stress is
enhancing mindset and there's a very
straightforward way to increase your
stress is enhancing mindset so first I
want to step back and acknowledge the
person who really made some of the key
fundamental discoveries in this area
that we call stresses enhancing mindsets
and that's Dr Alia sometimes referred to
as Dr Ali Crum she's a tenured professor
of psychology at Stanford she also is a
former division one athlete and a
licensed clinical psychologist she's an
absolute Phenom and I promise you that
she is so successful in all those
categories by way of immense amounts of
effort in addition to that she also
happens to be an incredibly kind person
and generous person she was a guest on
this podcast previously you can find
that episode in the show note captions
or by going to hubermanlab.com and
simply searching for mindset crumb
c-r-u-m
her personal story and her work and the
tool she offers are absolutely
spectacular however you don't need to go
to that episode just yet I'm going to
talk about some of those tools now and
I'm going to talk about how using those
tools can allow you to access growth
mindset and then I'm going to talk about
how the combination of applying a stress
is enhancing mindset with a growth
mindset acts synergistically to even
further improve performance in the short
and long run the stresses enhancing
mindset is the outgrowth of many
different studies and not just from Dr
Ali Crum but from others as well but for
the time being I want to focus on one
paper in which Dr Crum was the first
author so this work was done before she
arrived at Stanford the paper is
entitled rethinking stress the role of
mindsets in determining the stress
response and the key takeaway from this
paper is that how we think about stress
impacts how we react to stress so much
so in fact that what this paper
illustrates is that if people are given
even just a short tutorial about some of
the negative consequences of stress on
learning and performance and their
physiology and their health they
experience a lot of negative
consequences of stress when they are put
into a stressful circumstance
conversely if people are taught about
the performance enhancing aspects of
stress then those people will experience
performance enhancement when they are
confronted with stress in a learning or
other performance type environment so
what we are talking about here is not
the placebo effect I want to be very
clear about that
we are also not talking about lying to
people in order to shift their response
to stress what we're talking about here
is two different conditions one
condition where people are exposed to
information that is true about how
stress can diminish performance and
another condition in which people are
exposed to information that is also true
about how stress can enhance performance
now you might be saying how can it be
true that stress is both performance
diminishing and stress is performance
enhancing and ah therein lies the key
takeaway from this paper it depends on
what you believe about stress in fact a
different way to umbrella this whole
discussion is to say that how you think
about stress impacts the stress response
in profound ways so this paper
rethinking stress the role of mindsets
and determining stress
did a very simple set of manipulations
they had people in one group listen to a
lecture that effectively was titled
quote the effects of stress are negative
and should be avoided and that lecture
included information about how stress
diminishes performance and how it can
diminish health and vitality learning
and performance productivity it
increases uncertainty Etc okay and all
of that information is true
a separate group listened to a lecture
entitled quote experiencing stress
improves health and vitality and again
that information is true now I realize
that some of you are probably still
asking how can it be that stress
diminishes health and performance and
stress also enhances health and
performance and the answer lies in two
things one the level of stress and
therefore the level of hormones that are
released in response to that stress the
duration over which the stress response
occurs but the key variable here is that
our cognitive understanding about what
stress does impacts whether or not our
physiology goes down the direction of
debilitating or enhancing effects of
stress Okay so we've got a condition
here where people are being informed
very differently about what stress does
in one case it's the stresses bad
message in the other case it's the
stress is good message and there are
many different experiments within this
paper but one of the more interesting
ones I believe
is where they looked at work performance
both in terms of performance of what
they call soft tasks so these are
somewhat easier tasks as well as hard
tasks and when you look at the group
that was given information about how
stress diminishes performance in the
soft tasks okay so the somewhat easy
task You Don't See Much change in their
performance
as you compare the before the learning
about stress is diminishing to after the
learning whereas the people who learn
that stress is enhancing actually
experience some improvement in work
performance even though the challenge
that they're facing isn't that great so
again what this means is that learning
that stress can enhance performance by
providing people true information about
how stress can enhance performance can
increase performance even in the context
of stuff that's not that hard not that
stressful even more interesting is that
when you look at performance on tasks
that are considered hard and you compare
the stresses diminishing group meaning
the group that was taught that stress is
diminishing
and compare that to the stresses
enhancing group you see a really
Divergent response the people that learn
that stress diminishes performance did
not improve at all whereas the people
that learn that stress can enhance
performance enhance their performance
significantly now keep in mind all they
are doing is learning that stress can
enhance their performance and then
they're given the task and they're
performing better so that's pretty
spectacular right there's no training
session that they went and did they
didn't practice these items that they
were being tested on in between they
weren't given a bunch of you know drills
to do and they didn't take a lot of time
to do it they just heard a tutorial
about how stress can enhance performance
and that I believe is remarkable because
what it says is that our cognitive
appraisal about stress which we all are
going to experience in life right
elevated heart rate narrowing a visual
Focus you know shifting of blood away
from the periphery all of these things
are characteristic features of the
stress response that we learn especially
in this day and age because it's talked
about a lot in popular culture that oh
you know all of the these mechanisms
were put into us in order for us to get
away from the saber-toothed tiger or the
or the line that's trying to eat us
let's be fair the stress response is
there for a lot of reasons not just
because of saber-toothed tigers and
lions I mean that's kind of a story that
we make up the stress response is
inherent not just to us but to other
species as a way to mobilize us either
away from things or toward things right
we need to have somewhat of a stress
response in order to engage in adaptive
challenge yes it's true that hundreds
and thousands of years ago those
adaptive challenges probably involved
hunting but they probably involved
Social Challenges as well do you think
it was you know easy for cavemen and
women to engage socially and you know
kind of settle out their romantic
interactions Etc do you think it was
easy for them to raise children no of
course not the stress response is there
for a variety of reasons not just to get
away from predators the really exciting
thing that's been discovered in the
course of Ali krum's work and other work
in the last couple of decades is that
the stress response is neither good nor
bad the stress response depends on
whether or not you believe the
sensations that you're experiencing
elevated heart rate narrowing a visual
Focus Etc are serving to enhance your
performance or diminish your performance
and this study really points to the fact
that just learning that it can enhance
performance
can enhance performance now I know a
number of you are probably saying wait
but stress doesn't feel good right and
oftentimes we experience stress under
conditions where we're trying to learn
or get good at something or listen
better or do something and it actually
is diminishing performance I think it's
important to acknowledge that
this study and studies like it are not
saying that stress becomes pleasant as a
sensation in the body nor is it saying
that it always leads to improved
performance I don't want you to think
that's the take-home message sometimes
it does it can as was demonstrated in
this research paper but oftentimes as we
know stress diminishes our performance
it takes us away from the landmarks we
want to hit it takes us away from the
grades we want to get it takes us away
from quote unquote showing up how we
want to right no one wants to have the
blotchy skin and the sweating and the
quaking of voice when we're trying to do
public speaking and things of that sort
no one wants any of that what's
important to understand is that learning
that stress is a way of mobilizing
resources in the body does two things
first of all it allows us to dampen or
adjust the stress response in real time
and it allows us to understand that that
stress response heightens our level of
focus in a way that allows us to pay
attention to the things that are going
wrong in a way that allows us us to make
correction to those errors in the future
so if you think back to that study that
Erp study where they measured brain
activity and they looked at people who
had a fixed mindset versus people who
had a growth mindset and the people who
had a growth mindset were paying more
cognitive attention to what was
happening during errors and after errors
well this stress is enhancing mindset is
very powerful because what it does is it
shifts one's attention away from the
kind of somatic experience of oh my
goodness my heart rate is elevated I'm
sweating I'm quaking I'm just I sound
terrible I feel terrible I look terrible
Etc to a mode of allocating more of our
thinking toward analyzing why things
might be going wrong and something else
powerful happens when we Embrace a
stresses-enhancing mindset as well when
we Embrace a stress is enhancing mindset
it turns out that some of the very
physiological processes that we call
quote unquote stress shift in important
ways some of those include the duration
over which the stress hormone cortisol
is released and in fact I don't even
really want to call it a stress hormone
because cortisol does so many other
things as well and it's not bad you need
cortisol believe me you want cortisol
especially released early in the day and
in response to acute stressors what you
don't want is for cortisol to stay
elevated for long long periods of time
and you especially don't want it to
interfere with your sleep okay so much
so that I think at times I wonder
whether or not our philosophy on stress
should be that stress is fantastic for
us
except when it interferes with our sleep
right and when stress becomes terrible
for us is when it starts to be
chronically elevated and especially when
it starts to inhibit our ability to
sleep well enough and long enough okay
so the point here is that when we
Embrace a stressous enhancing mindset we
are able to have shorter duration
release of cortisol we are also able to
engage what's called increased stroke
volume under conditions of stress this
gets a little bit technical but the
amount of blood that your heart can pump
with each beat turns out to be a key
metric of stress when we are very
stressed even though we need to mobilize
a lot of resources somewhat
paradoxically our total stroke volume
can actually be reduced and we tend to
shuttle blood and other resources
towards the core of our body and towards
major Limbs and away from things like
our brain and our periphery so one of
the key measures of how a stress
response quote-unquote is going is how
much peripheral blood flow there is and
when we are more relaxed under
conditions of stress there tends to be
more peripheral blood flow when we are
more anxious more panicked under
conditions of stress peripheral blood
flow is lower and in a remarkable set of
experiments
Ali Crum and colleagues have shown that
when we are just taught that stress can
be enhancing and then we are placed into
a stressful environment either because
we are imagining stress or we are
experiencing real stress and then our
physiology is measured
what is observed is that the total
amount of blood that the heart can pump
with each beat is actually increase
peripheral blood flow increases and our
ability to maintain cognition to think
clearly under conditions of stress
increases and again the only
manipulation here is a tutorial about
how stress can be enhancing which is
essentially what I'm telling you right
now in fact for those of you that
perhaps have heard stress reduces
testosterone levels stress reduces
estrogen levels Etc that's true it is
also True by the way that when you are
informed about how stress can be
enhancing of performance it becomes
anabolic that's right it actually can
lead to deployment of androgens and
estrogens things that many not all
people desire to have increased or
certainly desire to not have diminished
below their normal Baseline so there's a
lot of false stories out there about
stress not false because what you're
hearing is wrong
because indeed chronic stress
chronically elevated cortisol can reduce
testosterone reduce estrogen diminish
sleep diminish immunity Etc
but it is also true that stress under
conditions where one believes that
stress can be enhancing can be anabolic
it can be pro-testosterone pro-estrogen
it can be
pro-cortisol regulation in ways that
allow you to focus your cognition and so
on and so forth now that's exciting but
I do realize that for some people it
might be sufficiently vague to make you
wonder well how do I know if I'm getting
the right response from stress or the
wrong response and the simple answer
there is the more that you can learn
about how stress can enhance performance
and the more that you place yourself
into safe I want to underscore it safe
yet stressful adaptive circumstances
these are going to be circumstances
where you stand to learn or grow in some
positive way not circumstances where you
stand to hurt yourself or others of
course
the more that you can place yourself
into conditions of stress and then to
cognitively just tell yourself ah this
elevated heart rate this um quaking of
my hands this you know sweating Etc this
is my body mobilizing resources and the
more that you can tell yourself that
that's actually affording you an
advantage in being able to allocate your
attention to specific things maybe why
you made an error and analyzing that or
maybe why you succeeded at something and
thinking about the steps that led to
that success the more that you can link
that back to the processes that are
taking you in the directions that you do
and don't want to go and thinking about
them because indeed that's what stress
can allow you to do
the more that you are shifting your mind
away from thinking about just the raw
uncomfortable sensations of stress
you're putting a cognitive appraisal on
a physiological process you are thinking
about stress in a way that is changing
what that stress is doing and you're
taking your brain and body from a
negative State just to put a little bit
of subjective valence on it negative
right nobody wants to have the bad
stress response to a positive State and
when you develop a stresses enhancing
mindset you not only are going to feel
more comfortable under conditions of
stress but you're also developing the
perfect tool to plug into the whole
process of building up your growth
mindset in a way that allows those two
things growth mindset and stress is
enhancing mindset to synergize and to
dramatically improve performance in the
short and long term and that's not just
a statement that I'm making that's what
the research tells us so let's take a
look at that research so now I'd like to
shift our discussion to some very recent
findings about growth mindset and how
growth mindset combined with the
stresses enhancing mindset can
powerfully change outcomes for the
better and can do so in a huge variety
of real world contexts and the work that
I'm referring to is the work of a person
named David Yeager Dr David Yeager is a
professor at the University of Texas
Austin he did his graduate work with
Carol dweck at Stanford and he now has
his own laboratory in Austin and both
when he was a graduate student with
Carol and in his own laboratory he's
been doing very impressive large-scale
studies meaning many thousands of
subjects so that itself is important and
using subjects from diverse areas rural
urban Etc different levels of affluence
lack of affluence and finding
essentially that when students are
taught about a growth mindset what it is
how it's different than a fixed mindset
and when those same students are also
taught about what a stress is enhancing
mindset is and cultivating that again
simply through information tutorial
watching a video about growth mindset
watching a video about stress is
enhancing
mindsets and then
confronted with stress
confronted with Tess confronted with
opportunities to embrace hard challenges
or easier paths across the board the
results show up again and again as
students who are taught about a growth
mindset and are taught that stress is
enhancing perform better now jaegering
colleagues have shown that across a huge
number of different experiments in fact
there's a paper published quite recently
this was about a year ago in July of
2022 in the journal Nature so Apex
Journal published as a full article in
Nature and Science and elsewhere they
have letters and shorter formats like
reports and then there are the Articles
which correspond to major major findings
so they published The Following results
as an article in nature in July of 2022
the title of the paper is a synergistic
mindsets intervention protects
adolescents from stress and what I
absolutely love about this paper is that
it includes a lot of different kinds of
experiments so for instance
they looked at high school students who
simply anticipated a stressful event and
had been instructed on growth mindset or
stress's enhancing mindset or both or
control
conditions where they weren't informed
of those mindsets right It's always
important to have control experiments
where you're getting the same amount of
information but it's not the same
information and what they found was that
anticipatory stress right the stress
that we feel in anticipation of
something that we think is going to
happen is reduced when we are educated
about growth mindset and we are educated
about a stress's enhancing mindset and
the basic takeaway from that experiment
was yes indeed being educated on what a
growth mindset is and how it differs
from a fixed mindset which you now have
been educated on
definitely buffers you against stress in
addition being educated on how stress
can enhance performance can buffer you
against anticipatory stress
but it is clearly the case that when one
is educated on both of those things
growth mindset and stresses enhancing
mindsets that one observes the greatest
buffering or offset of the stress
response in ways that can improve
performance now that is but one
experiment of the six yes six
experiments included in this single
Paper now I'm not going to go through
each of those six experiments in detail
and just as a side note I've invited Dr
David Yeager to be a guest on this
podcast and he has agreed so when he's a
guest on this podcast I'm sure he will
detail all the intricacies of those
experiments in order to inform us about
exactly what was done and how so that we
can benefit from that information but
just by way of example another
experiment in this paper
use what was called the trigger social
stress test and the reason I'm going to
highlight this a little bit is because I
think it relates to a lot of things that
many of us have experienced and that
will experience that are considered
stressful and of course we would all
like ways to buffer ourselves against
stress and or leverage that stress to
improve our performance
as well as adopt a growth mindset so the
try our social stress test is a kind of
standard mode of stressing people out in
the laboratory or in the classroom where
basically a subject comes in you tell
them to wait a little bit of time then
you measure their stress response at
rest you're looking at their heart rate
their blood pressure you might have them
spit into a little tube and use that
saliva to measure cortisol because
that's how you measure cortisol
then you're going to tell them that
they're going to prepare a speech for
presentation in front of a small group
of actual people then they actually have
to deliver that speech in front of that
audience during that speech sometimes
the people who are observing it are
giving feedback like frowns crossed arms
Etc
then there's a pop quiz where they get a
hard arithmetic test in front of that
audience and when they get answer is
wrong they're told they're wrong in
front of that audience this all might
seem kind of playful and silly to you
but most people do not experience this
as playful and silly almost everybody
who goes into one of these experiments
as a subject
feel some level of stress especially
those that don't like public speaking
especially those that don't see
themselves as very proficient in
arithmetic or that don't like to work
out problems in real time in front of
people you can see how this would be
stressful and all the while measures of
psychological and physiological
reactivity are being measured peripheral
blood flow the thing we talked about
earlier among those what I just
described is pretty extensive but I
provide all that as a backdrop
so that you can understand what happened
before which was people were simply
educated on growth mindset how it
differs from fixed mindset and or stress
enhances performance mindset or not
so basically what we have here is a
condition in which people are just
getting information right there's no
pill there's no treadmill there's no
going home and doing a bunch of problem
sets and what they observe in this
experiment and all the other experiments
contained within this quite massive
paper
is that the mere learning about growth
mindset and stresses enhancing mindsets
allows these students to shift their
physiology
so enhance peripheral blood flow changes
in hormone secretion like cortisol n
shifts in their psychology such that
when they feel stressed they start to
see that and experience that as an
opportunity for Challenge and to lean
into that challenge and where they are
told that they got the wrong answer
where they are told that they are not
performing well they are able to think
about that and to allocate their mental
resources such that they do start to
perform better and the major takeaway
from the study is that across the board
in all six experiments in Imagine stress
in real stress laboratory stress actual
classroom stress and in embracing future
challenges
just the learning about what stress can
enhance your performance mindset is
allowed students to do just that now
another really interesting feature of
this study put out by Jager and
colleagues was that the interventions
were one time and relatively brief or we
could even say extremely brief whereas a
lot of previous experiments had looked
at growth mindset interventions that
were on the order of you know four to
six to eight tutorials lasting anywhere
from 30 minutes to an hour each this
experiment employed just one 30-minute
intervention
so when I heard about these results and
read the paper I got very excited I
wanted to know what is this magic
intervention exactly and I'm sure you're
thinking the same so I contacted Dr
Yeager and he was gracious enough to
provide me some examples of what's
contained within this tutorial so that I
could give you those examples in real
time during this episode so basically
the tutorial starts off with a question
about stress it actually has a little
field where you can fill in an answer to
the following question
can you recall a time when you
experienced stress and what was that
stress related to and here I'm
paraphrasing so what I put in response
to this because I actually filled out
the form itself was when I was a postdoc
which by the way is the four to six year
period of time that comes after your PhD
training
I wrote when I was a postdoc
I was under a lot of competitive
pressure to try and finish my projects I
was working under a diminished income
meaning I wasn't getting paid very much
relative to the cost of living in the
area I lived at the time and I was also
socially isolated from a lot of my
friends that previously I had lived very
close to that was a stressful time that
I could recall in fact no other time in
my life as I recall was as stressful as
being a postdoc which is not to say that
I didn't enjoy being a postdoc I
delighted in doing the science I did and
being surrounded by the people I was
surrounded by but it was very very
stressful for those and additional
reasons so that's how this tutorial
starts off and I believe that the reason
that they asked that question at the
beginning of the tutorial is to kind of
cue up cognitive mechanisms that
surround one's own understanding of
stress and then as you click through the
tutorial
it starts to explain of all things
neuroscience and neuroplasticity it says
research from Neuroscience tells us that
through effort our brain can change it
can form new connections that we call
synapses so of course I was delighted to
see all that information I'm very
familiar with that type of information
It also says things like and here I'm
reading directly from the tutorial
difficulty struggle and frustration when
you're learning something are not signs
that you've reached your limits they're
signs that you're expanding your limits
okay then you go to the next field and
it says
let's hear from a scientist Urie
triceman is one of the top calculus
professors here's what he tells us
students on the first day of class
quote everyone in this class will
struggle no matter who you are questions
are going to be flying at you that you
cannot answer and when that happens
you're going to experience stress and if
you don't understand that stress you'll
think it means oh no I don't belong here
but in fact that stress is an indicator
that your understanding is deepening
it's not a sign that you're not learning
it's a sign that you are learning okay
so I could read this entire tutorial for
you but that would take up far too much
of our time but I think you get the
essence of it which is that with each
slide within the tutorial you're being
told that the thing that you're
experiencing that could potentially feel
negative because it means negative
things you're not learning you're
suffering you're suffering health-wise
you're suffering performance wise
is reappraised it's telling you no the
frustration the agitation the thought
that you're not capable and you're not
capable of getting better it's actually
the opposite so what this tutorial
really is is it's an information based
tutorial it tells you something about
the brain's capacity to change it gives
you some True by the way mechanistic
information about how synapses can
change and brain circuits can change
because indeed they can
and it's telling you that the negative
somatic bodily and cognitive
thought-based experiences of stress that
those represent you getting better
that's simply what it is and despite it
being simple in its specific message
that message turns out to be incredibly
powerful how can we say that it's truly
powerful well we could turn to
essentially any page in this study that
Jaeger and colleagues did and see that
for instance the intervention again this
is the combination of learning about
growth mindset and learning that stress
can be performance enhancing
led to 40 Improvement in self-regard so
self-regard is something that can be
measured we can have very negative or
very positive self-regard 40
improvements in self-regard there was a
14 Improvement in passing of courses
that were of the particularly
challenging type and there was also a
significant Improvement in passing of
courses that were less challenging in
addition to that people who watched and
engaged in this 30 minute tutorial also
took on additional hard challenges in
the future long after the intervention
had ceased now there are a number of
other features of the David Yeager work
that I think are especially important to
consider but rather than go into the
specifics of those experiments
I'm going to frame them in the context
of some very specific tools that I've
spelled out for sake of this episode
based on the scientific literature that
you can use in order to build a growth
mindset and in order to build the stress
enhances performance mindset now in some
sense all of our discussion during this
episode up until now has served as a
tutorial about growth mindset and about
stress enhances performance and how
those two things can be combined in
order to get a synergistic positive
effect nonetheless I do think that it's
useful especially when thinking about
cognitive tools which are often less
concrete and clear to people how they
can Implement them compared to say
exercise tools like you know get two 100
minutes of Zone 2 cardio per week or get
six sets of resistance exercise per
major muscle group per week Etc all of
that stuff in the physical domain is
very concrete whereas stuff that relates
to tools in the cognitive domain
sometimes can feel a little bit abstract
so for that we reason I'm just going to
take a couple of minutes and list off
some of the key elements to building up
a growth mindset and a stress enhances
performance mindset that are gleaned
from the literature that I've talked
about now and related literature the
first tool is that whenever possible if
both the teacher and the student can
adopt a growth mindset and a stress
enhances performance mindset that's the
best case scenario this has been shown
in the classroom and it's been shown in
other contexts as well and again it
simply means learning about what growth
mindset is and how it differs from fixed
mindset it also ideally means learning
how stress can enhance performance now
if that means
spending some time with the discussion
that we had around Dr Alia crum's data
that would be great if it also means
just thinking about the stress response
and understanding that that stress
response indeed is mobilizing resources
it's focusing your vision more narrowly
right you sort of lose the forest
through the trees and yet that allows
you to really analyze carefully whatever
it is that you choose to focus your
attention on well then that's going to
be performance enhancing again these
tools are purely cognitive but they are
well supported by the data and the data
also tell us that when teachers and
students both adopt this mindset the
teachers are viewing the students as
less fixed in their abilities and the
students are viewing themselves as less
fixed in their abilities the next tool
which is a really fundamental one to
everything we're talking about was
actually mentioned at the beginning of
the episode which is whenever giving
praise or giving feedback of any kind to
others or to yourself perhaps even
especially to yourself
make the effort to make that feedback
about verbs not labels okay to really
think about
praising or in some cases maybe giving
feedback about how effort could have
been better but ideally you're saying
great effort it was great that when you
missed that shot on goal that you ran
back to your side of the field it was
great that when you didn't perform well
on that math exam
that you went back to those problem sets
and that you conversed with other
students about why they had performed a
certain way and you really dug through
it and figured out why you got things
wrong now a key aspect of this tool of
focusing on verbs not labels is that it
is especially important to do this when
you've performed well I talked about the
reasons a little bit earlier but I
cannot emphasize this enough when you've
performed well if you tell yourself or
you tell somebody else that they're just
a great athlete they're just a great
student they're talented they're
brilliant I promise you you are
undermining their future performance
when they inevitably encounter challenge
if however you give yourself or the
other person feedback that's really
grounded in effort and persistence in
problem solving you are absolutely going
the right direction now if you are going
to give feedback about errors either to
yourself or to somebody else
the question really is do you paint that
with rose-colored glasses do you try and
make it seem like the errors weren't
that bad that's not actually what we're
talking about we're not talking about
what do they say putting lipstick on a
pig what we're talking about is
looking at those errors and thinking
about what led up to those errors and
trying to put more of our cognitive
attention on the verbs the things that
led to those errors and less of our
attention on the emotions related to
those errors we really need to be
analytic about those errors and
admittedly
we often need to take a day or two or
maybe even longer before we can do that
process effectively right nothing that
I've said thus far has said that we have
to do all of this immediately after an
error or immediately after a poor
performance sometimes we are so caught
up in the emotional experience of having
performed not as well as we would have
liked that there's simply no way that we
can allocate our mental resources toward
error analysis ideally we can but
oftentimes we can so we have to be how
do they say gentle with ourselves and
allow ourselves to move through that
process and then get back to error
analysis that's absolutely key but we
really want to focus on the verbs
leading to those errors not putting
labels on the stupid ridiculous silly
fill in your blank with whatever
negative label you might happen to come
up with okay so verbs verbs verbs for
analyzing why we did well and verbs
verbs verbs for analyzing why we did
poorly now you may have noticed that a
few minutes ago I mentioned that
oftentimes it's beneficial that when we
make errors that we seek out others who
either performed well
ideally but also those who performed
poorly in order to get some
understanding as to why we did not
perform as well as we wanted and that
raises another key tool there are a lot
of data now to support the fact that one
of the key ways to analyze our errors is
to get help and this is one of the
things that really differentiates the
high performers from the low performers
over time and yes there I just used a
label well I guess I could have said the
high effort which leads to Performance
people versus the low effort which leads
to low performance people but in any
case you get the idea people who perform
well over time
regardless of labels that we place on
them tend to be people who seek help in
order to understand why they didn't
perform well so this is a core component
of not just trying and building a growth
mindset but really solidifying a growth
mindset and a stress can enhance
performance mindset so seek help from
others in understanding where you didn't
perform as well as you like and I would
say Seek input from others as to what
were the verbs that you think might have
led to your heightened performance
because we like to think that we have
really good Optics on why we did well oh
yeah it was because I spent X number of
hours practicing but oftentimes those
around us have additional perspectives
that we can't access and learning about
those perspectives of why we've
performed poorly but also why we
performed well
in the context of these verbs not labels
is also tremendously beneficial the
other thing that's clear from the
literature on growth mindset and stress
can enhance performance mindset
is that
all of that stuff all those tutorials
are most effective when both teachers
and students Embrace those mindsets now
that's a wonderful situation if teachers
and students are both available and
willing to learn those mindsets however
for many of us we don't have a teacher
we don't have a mentor we're doing all
of this on our own
and so what's fortunate is that there
are also data in the literature showing
that under conditions where either the
teacher or the mentor is not there or is
not embracing a growth mindset or stress
enhances performance mindset we actually
can serve as our own teacher
by using a simple tool and the simple
tool that was actually the same tool
that was used in one of the Jaeger
studies is to take maybe a three by five
card or an eight and a half by eleven
sheet of paper and write out a letter
as if you're writing a letter to the
next person coming along trying to get
good at the thing that you're trying to
get good at and explain to them what
growth mindset is and how it differs
from a fixed mindset explain to them
what the stress enhances performance
mindset is how to adopt it and how it
can amplify performance
that simple exercise of writing a letter
which is essentially to oneself but
you're sort of pretending that the
letter is for somebody else although I
suppose you could and perhaps should
give it to somebody else so they can
benefit that simple exercise has been
shown to improve one's own performance
and to do so in dramatic ways not just
in the immediate term but also in the
future now the final tool I'd like to
share is one that I've come up with but
it's one that's really grounded in the
Neuroscience of neuroplasticity
and believe it or not that's grounded in
our understanding of exercise physiology
and that is to reframe this idea that
the mind is like a muscle I know we hear
that over and over again the mind is
like a muscle you know you exercise a
muscle it gets stronger
you exercise your mind you put it
through some strain and you can learn
those statements are absolutely true but
this statement that the mind is like a
muscle that analogy falls short I
believe in an important way that can
lead a lot of people astray when they
try and embrace growth mindset and the
stress enhances performance mindset and
the reason I say that is the following
exercise with weights or resistance
training of any kind whether or not it's
body weight or machines or free weights
has an incredible property to it in that
it increases blood flow to the muscles
that we're training right this is
something that really distinguishes
resistance training from other forms of
training like long distance running
when we train our muscles with
resistance the blood flow into that
muscle the so-called pump gives us a
sort of a hint or a window of the growth
of that muscle that is likely to occur
if we allow that muscle to recover after
that resistance training in other words
resistance training provides us a kind
of hint of the results we are likely to
get so when we hear the analogy that the
mind is like a muscle I think it falls
short because when we strain to learn
something with our mind we don't
actually get to feel what it is to
perform much better
as we are trying to learn that thing
actually quite the contrary in fact much
of what we've been talking about today
is the fact that the stress and strain
and the disappointment that is so
reflexively felt when we look at our
diminished performances we're trying to
learn is actually the trigger for
invoking the learning itself so what I'm
saying here is that it is not the case
that when we go in to learn a language
or a new skill or
mathematics or something new that for a
moment we are fluent or partially fluent
and then we lose that ability when we
walk out of the classroom or the
tutorial
that's what makes it different than the
gym where you go and you lift weights or
you use a resistance training of any
kind and you get this sort of window
into oh this is what the muscle will
feel like and look like when it's larger
so the mind is like a muscle analogy
sort of works in the sense that if you
properly stress a muscle using
resistance training and then you give it
an adequate amount of time to recover it
indeed will get bigger and stronger
and it is true that when you go in to
try and learn something if you provide
the adequate stress which is hitting
that point where you're not
understanding the information it's not
sinking in and you give yourself some
time to recover which requires sleep by
the way
then you'll learn that new information
over time but where the mind is like a
muscle analogy really Falls away I
believe is that the mind is not like a
muscle because you don't actually get to
experience the good growth that you're
seeking as you're trying to learn it
rather everything we've been talking
about today is about learning how to
experience the strain of trying to learn
the agitation of trying to learn as the
learning process itself and
understanding that while you might feel
back on your heels a little or a lot
during that process that you might and
in fact very likely are going to
experience all the category of things
that go along with stress elevated heart
rate frustration you know maybe even a
little headache or strain difficulty
maintaining Focus Etc that if you
understand that all of those things are
actually creating the specific
neurochemical and neural circuit
conditions to invoke learning well then
that learning will occur so in some ways
a better analogy would be if it were the
case that when you do resistance
training that your muscles actually got
smaller during the training and then
rebounded to being even bigger than they
were prior to the training that would be
the appropriate analogy for the mind is
like a muscle I say all this because yes
adopting a growth mindset is incredibly
valuable adopting a stress can enhance
performance mindset is incredibly
valuable and even more valuable is
combining those two mindsets because
they do indeed improve performance
synergistically however none of this
process is expected to be reflexive for
most people perhaps for anybody and the
process of building up these mindsets
involves another mindset which is the
one that umbrellas them all or gathers
them all together and makes them really
work which is the idea that mindsets are
indeed powerful that they can have a
real effect and that while they do take
time to cultivate they can be cultivated
thank you for joining me today for our
discussion about growth mindset what it
is and how to cultivate a growth mindset
as well as the related stress can dance
performance mindset which can also be
cultivated
if you're learning from and are enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a five
star review if you have questions for me
or comments about the podcast or guests
that you'd like me to invite onto the
uberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comments section on YouTube I do
read all the comments in addition please
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not so much in today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep hormone
support and focus the uberman Lab
podcast has partnered with momentous
supplements if you're interested in
learning about the supplements discussed
on the huberman Lab podcast you can go
to live momentous spelled ous so that's
livemomentis.com huberman if you're not
already following me on social media I'm
hubermanlab on all social media
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
Twitter threads LinkedIn and Facebook
and on all of those platforms I cover
science and science-based tools some of
which overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content on the
huberman Lab podcast
if you haven't already subscribed to our
neural network newsletter the neural
network newsletter is a monthly
newsletter it's completely zero cost and
it provides podcast summaries and
toolkits of things like neuroplasticity
sleep deliberate cold exposure exercise
and so on to sign up for the neural
network newsletter simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu scroll
down a newsletter and provide your email
we do not share your email with anybody
and again it's completely zero cost
thank you once again for joining me for
today's discussion all about growth
mindset and related mindsets for
improving performance and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]